okay today I'm going to talk to you
about ultraviolet radiation we're gonna
have a look at some of the uses and
dangers so to begin with ultraviolet is
part of the electromagnetic spectrum it
has a higher frequency than all of these
types of radiation and it has a lower
frequency than x-rays and gamma-rays
because it's part of the electromagnetic
spectrum it travels at around 300
million meters per second in a vacuum
and it's a type of transverse wave so to
begin with one use of ultraviolet
radiation are in these things called
security pens and I'll show you just now
what security pens are actually used for
so let's imagine that I've just brought
bought myself a brand new laptop now
what I can do is I can get a security
pan and on the back of the laptop so if
I close it up and on the back of the
laptop what I can do is I can sign my
name so here's my unique signature for
my new laptop now the reason why this is
used is when I'm from a sign it my
security pen this is actually not
visible currently so I wouldn't actually
see anything at this stage now the
purpose of this is if someone was to
steal my laptop this security pen this
signature might come in really helpful
the reason for that is because of this
if the police were to to find the person
who stole the laptop the person might
claim that it was their laptop but what
the police can do is they can shine UV
radiation ultraviolet radiation onto the
laptop where I said my signature would
be and what will happen is the special
chemicals within the security pen within
the ink they absorb the ultraviolet
radiation and they emit visible light
and what actually will happen is that
signature will glow and it will indicate
that
not their product its it's in fact my
product this could help convict the
person who stole a laptop it can also
help to return the property now this
particular phenomenon is called
fluorescence so it's the idea of
ultraviolet substances that absorb
ultraviolet radiation and emit visible
light
now fluorescence is also important in
the other uses that we need to know
about ultraviolet radiation which is
helping to detect forgery so every day
people try and forge things such as
banknotes and passports so what they've
done to try and try and protect protect
basically against forgery so in my
apologies for for this little picture of
the Queen what they try and do to
protect against forgery is they put
special markings on for example
banknotes like this 20 pound note here
so what happens is this again under
ultraviolet radiation this the special
markings here absorbed ultraviolet
radiation and again they emit give out
visible light so again we should see
this kind of glowing brightly again an
example of fluorescence in order to
detect forgery is it's easy enough to
print the notes but it's not as easy to
include the special markets the
fluoresce under ultraviolet radiation so
this is how they can use in stores if
they hold the note under an ultraviolet
light then they should be able to see
the note glowing and fluorescing is it
giving gives out visible light if it
doesn't then it's a good charge that
it's forged so this could be used to
detect forgery of banknotes and also
like I said passports now it's not just
those of those the uses we're now going
to have a look at some of the dangers
now as we can see ultraviolet
radiation it's close to this side of the
scale meaning it has quite a high
frequency now the further we go this way
the more dangerous these types of
radiation are because they transfer more
energy we describe ultraviolet as being
ionizing radiation which means it can
actually cause some damage the reason
for that is this so let's imagine this
is this is someone's arm now this is why
it's important to wear sunblock when
you're out in a lot of Sun because what
can happen is the ultraviolet radiation
which is present in sunlight can can
basically come into contact with your
skin and because it's ionizing due to
quite a high frequency it can cause skin
cancer so it can actually ionize your
cells now there's another video to show
that exact process but just to know that
it can cause skin cancer now that's not
the only problem this that I'm drawing
is just an eye from the side to the side
view of the eye if we have too much
ultraviolet radiation going into our
eyes it can actually damage our eyes and
in very severe case it'll not damage
cells damaged eyes and in very severe
cases it can cause blindness so that is
basically the uses of ultraviolet
radiation and the dangers thank you